so how about this a mini series where I
play a handsome astronaut who ages in
Reverse right great great talking Ian
James Cameron this assistant ooh
Oh oh my god you scared me don't bring
up God okay I'm the devil remember
you're not getting my soul you haven't
lived up to your end of the bargain what
are you talking about you're a famous
hot person that was the deal no the deal
was I'd be a famous movie star you're
one of the biggest movie stars of all
time I loved you an edge of tomorrow was
Tom Cruise really he was great
but anyway I just wanted to say have fun
tonight but I gotta head out you're not
staying
no I hate roast or to mean well would
you have any advice yes take everything
personally open with your best rape joke
and if the night goes slow just go into
the audience grab a baby and slap it
wait a minute that's terrible advice I
give terrible advice of a terrible guy
just like that character you played in
Tropic Thunder that was Tom Cruise I did
it again so after tonight you're taking
my soul no I can't you already sold your
soul when you did those stupid Direct TV
commercials now go on out there give as
good as you get hey Rollo I gotta come
clean I know I look amazing but I'm not
the devil this is a fake tail this this
comes off I'm weird I'd and barely funny
televisions Amy Poehler
five years ago in Parks and Rec we
thought it would be funny to pull this
prank but it feels mean now I'm sorry
good try mr. devil god bless that
beautiful dummy no live tweet in this
bitch